Huh
Hey miss Potts if you find this recording
Don't feel bad about this
Part of the journey use the end
Just for the record being adrift in space with zero promise of rescue is more fun, that sounds
Food and water ran out four days ago
Oxygen allowed out tomorrow morning
Back then
When I drift off I will dream about you
It's how I see you
Danos did exactly what he said he was gonna do
He wiped out
50% of all living creatures
We lost all of us
The lost friends who lost family
We lost a part of ourselves
This is the fight of our lives
This is gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I don't know what I'm gonna do if it doesn't
Hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang
We met a few years ago at the airport in Germany my job really big. It's just an old message
I
know, you know, that's
Right, that's me. Can you buzz me?